>> From The Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Good afternoon, I'm Taru Spiegel
from the Library's European Division
and welcome to this program about
Jean Sibelius and Fritz Kreisler.
And many thanks to the Embassy
of Finland, Keijo Karjalainen
and the Library's Music
Division, Anne McClain,
David Plylar [phonetic]
and Jen Loritson [phonetic]
for making the event possible.
Also the great technical staff
who makes us look professional,
thank goodness.
We're happy to have Jani Lehtonen
and Jani Aarrevaara
as our speakers today.
And, let me tell you, it was
very, very hard to get 2 speakers
with the same first name
[laughter], but we managed.
And we also get extra points
because the names Jani and Jean,
as in Jean Sibelius are related.
As you know, this year marks the
150th anniversary of the birth
of Jean Sibelius, whose
actual birthday was yesterday.
And we're glad to remember this
great Finnish composer and also
to highlight one of the Library's
treasures, the original manuscript
of the Fritz Kreisler
piano arrangement
of Sibelius's lovely violin
concerto "Opus 47 D Minor".
And the treasure is right
there, being guarded by David.
And why and when this Kreisler
reduction was made is a mystery
that today's speakers
will look into.
Sibelius was born in
Finland in 1865 and Kreisler
in Austria, 10 years later.
Both were extremely
famous in their lifetime
and are still well loved
by audiences worldwide.
Today's talk will focus on
a lesser known conjunction
of these superstars.
I would like to mention that the
Library's holdings include more
than an thousand titles
relating to Sibelius.
Also, unique here, is the
Fritz Kreisler collection
which includes manuscripts,
personal papers and correspondence.
The music division serves
materials for your music inquiries
and the European Division
would be the place to go
to for various European
language materials including
Finnish material.
Jani Lehtonen is first violinist
of the Helsinki City Orchestra,
Concertmaster of Joensuu City
Orchestra as well as lead violin
with the Philharmonic
Entertainment Strings and a member
in the prize-winning
Arcadia Quartet.
He studied at the Sibelius Academy
and the Royal Danish
Academy of Music.
Lehtonen's been a soloist with the
Helsinki City Orchestra as well
as the Aalborg and Odense
Symphony Orchestras among others.
In 2007, he received a special award
at the XI Concorso Violino
Citta di Brescia Competition.
His sound recordings include Haydn,
Kuchler, Segestrom and Kreisler.
Jani Aarrevaara teaches
piano on the faculty
of the Tampere Music Conservatory.
He graduated from [inaudible]
Music Academy
and received his concert diplome
under the direction of
Erik Apel [phonetic].
He has taught piano
at various Finnish
and German music institutions.
One of Aarrevaara's awards
led to a concert tour
that included Carnegie Hall--
a Carnegie Hall performance
and his repertoire consists
of chamber music and lead.
And together the Janis published a
Kreisler CD in 2012, they're working
on another one that's
looking for a publisher
that features this
Kreisler reduction.
And they've done a lot of
research on this material.
We hope to see it published
maybe one day.
Finally, for the fun bit,
please note that the
event is being videotaped
and please turn your
cell phones off.
So, I'll have a little talk
here with Jani Lehtonen.
So, Janie, what led you here to
talk about Kreisler and Sibelius?
>> When Jani Aarrevaara and I
made our first joint recording
of Fritz Kreisler's work
for violin and piano,
I learned a lot about
Kreisler's life.
Our CD published in 2012 contains
a number of known, and less known,
compositions created by
this master violinist
and composer during
his remarkable career.
When writing the booklet for the
CD, [inaudible] excellent biography
of Fritz Kreisler, "Love's Joy,
Love's Sorrow" was a great help.
It is possibly the most
comprehensive work in this area.
Biancolli's book ends
with a complete listing
of Kreisler's work made
during his lifetime.
Looking at this, my
interest was sparked
by the Sibelius violin concerto
Opus 47 D Minor arrangement
for piano and violin.
>> So you had mentioned that
this was a big surprise,
this information about manuscript?
>> Yes. The information about
the Sibelius arrangement was
so interesting for a Finnish
violinist that I began
to investigate where I could
find the music material.
The Biancolli's list
of works stated only
that this was an unpublished
work held here
at the U.S. Library of Congress.
I spoke about the matter with some
well-informed people in Finland,
and it turned out that the Finnish
National Radio Library had a copy
of the Library of Congress
manuscript
which is over there on the table.
I received a top duplicate copy
from them [inaudible]
library [inaudible].
At this stage, I still
didn't know what to expect
because Kreisler had made a number
of published and, thus well-known,
arrangement of violin concertos
by different composers as well
as other works whose structure
he had completely changed.
One can therefore rather
speak about these
as new compositions using
someone else's technique.
This, however, was not the
case regarding the Sibelius
violin concerto.
Kreisler had kept the solo violin
part unchanged, in other words,
just as Sibelius had composed it,
except for some very
minor violinist details
which may be considered
editorial suggestions rather
than actual changes.
>> So when you found the manuscript
copy, what was your next step?
What did you decide to do?
>> We decided to actually
record the whole thing.
It was so good that it would be nice
for other people really
hear that music.
And, actually, the background music
when you came in this hall was
from the CD made by us last year.
And we are now waiting for
a publisher for this CD.
>> So you did a considerable
amount of research
on the Kreisler reduction.
>> Yeah. Despite our
efforts, we have been unable
to find any written references
about the Kreisler piano reduction
of the Sibelius violin
concert, so all the conclusions
about this version are our own.
Why Fritz Kreisler made
his own piano reduction
of the Sibelius concerto
remains a great mystery so far,
especially since Sibelius
also made his own reduction
of the piece in 1905.
Also the date of the
Kreisler reduction is unknown.
Future research may clarify if Jean
Sibelius had time to work the violin
and orchestra concerto into
his 1905 arrangement for piano
and violin before Kreisler
made his own version.
Did Fritz Kreisler and
Jean Sibelius ever meet?
Both are historic superstars
in their day
and were only 10 years apart in age.
As far as we know, Kreisler
visited Finland twice and, thus,
a meeting would have been possible.
Did Sibelius know about
Kreisler's piano reduction
and did Kreisler have the
composer's permission?
We don't know.
From the point of view of research
into the recent history of music,
it would be most enlightening to
find answers to these questions.
>> Okay, I have just a little aside.
I was reading a little bit about
Kreisler and I'm not sure if he got
to Finland this time, but
he was playing in Russia
and met a Finnish girl and wanted
to leave everything behind.
This was when he was
young and foolish, right?
>> Okay.
>> But he was persuaded
to go back [laughter].
So, anyway, what do you
think was the reason
for the Kreisler reduction?
>> Generally speaking, the events
that revolutionized musical culture,
radio and records, also radically
changed music consumption habits.
Before this breakthrough, it was
only possible to enjoy live music.
This meant that mostly only
the upper classes were able
to pursue music at the high level.
It has also largely affected
how music was published.
For instance, Felix Mendelssohn
Bartholdy secured a contract
from his publisher for the famous
E Minor Concerto for Violin
and Orchestra only on condition
that he also prepare a
piano reduction based
on the orchestration
as soon as possible.
In other words, classical
music in its own time was first
and foremost consumer music.
It was performed not just at actual
concerts, but at home in silence
and for festive occasions often with
a reduced configuration not least
because of the various
more number of orchestras.
>> So about a hundred years ago,
you and Jani Aarrevaara would have
been playing this piece at home
for your friends and family
or at some local event?
>> Correct.
>> Yeah?
>> In times past, recital concerts
were far more common than today.
The artist would either play or sing
most often to piano accompaniment.
This seems strange to us
today because we are used
to hearing live performances
for solo instruments
or orchestras only as
a part of a concert.
Even until the Second World War,
it was usual for violin recitals
to feature a violin concerto with
piano accompaniment in addition
to music similarly
configured for the program.
During Fritz Kreisler's career,
this was not at all uncommon.
The fact that he created a reduction
for the Sibelius violin
concerto definitively indicates
that the work made a
significant impression on him
because a reduction requires
a lot of work and time.
And I can show you, it is
really a huge amount of work.
These are our copies of
the original manuscript
which you can look at on the table.
It's 39 pages handwrited music.
It's really great job he has
done so I would say it takes
at least weeks just to
write this whole thing.
But he also made this great work of
arranging the whole concerto again
from the big orchestral
score for piano score.
>> So was the Sibelius
concerto well-known
when Sibelius composed
it in 1904, right?
>> Yeah. I would say yes and no
because the first time it
was performed in Helsinki,
the first version, it wasn't
very successful thing.
And, afterwards, Sibelius made huge
corrections for his violin concerto.
And this is a revised
version we nowadays know
and hear soloists playing.
And this Kreisler's
work is also based
on this revised Sibelius
violin concerto.
And but it wasn't very famous
before Jascha Heifetz recorded it.
But, afterwards, it has been maybe
the most successful violin concerto
ever composed.
And nowadays, the amount of
recordings is over 60 recordings
of Sibelius violin
concerto so it means
that it is most recorded
violin concerto ever composed
on 20th century.
>> So, Jascha Heifetz made
this known in the '30s, right?
>> Yes, I think so.
It was in the '30s.
>> So, it wasn't really
such a super, super,
super hit when Kreisler
did the reduction, so.
>> No, no, that's right.
>> So, any conclusions about
the Kreisler reduction?
>> I would say that,
like I said before,
he was a really great
affected about Sibelius music.
And we have to remember that
he was extremely gifted person
as a violinist, but
also as a composer.
When he got the place from Vienna
Conservatory at 7 years old,
his first teacher was
Anton Bruckner really.
And composing was also
main part on his studies.
And he was remarkably talented
to produce music by heart
and also arrange other
composers' works
for his own instrument especially.
But he was also really good pianist.
So that's why this reduction
for Sibelius concerto
is really interesting.
And I would say it's a real
treasure for violinists, pianists
and also music lovers
all over the world.
>> So the quality is good,
you said, yeah, yeah.
>> Yes, it's, it's brilliant.
>> Yeah.
>> So, as was mentioned before,
Sibelius also created an arrangement
of this concerto so what
are the differences?
>> I think we could ask
this from other Jani now,
he has some kind of show so.
>> Should I start with the show?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> So, hello.
Yes, in the following, I
will present some notes
on Kreisler's reduction
in comparison
with Sibelius's own reduction.
I will also play some samples
from our CD and some samples
with the orchestra,
a couple of samples.
Apparently, there are at least 3
reductions of Sibelius's concerto,
Sibelius's own reduction
from 1905 like we just heard
from the same time when he finished
his second version, last version,
of the concerto, a reduction
by Alexandre Gretchaninoff,
a Russian composer from 1942 which,
according to Sibelius's secretary,
Santeri Levas, was
something Sibelius also liked.
You can read one sentence of this,
of this reduction in the biography
by Santeri Levas, and the third one,
the unpublished Fritz
Kreisler's reduction.
Compared to Sibelius, Kreisler uses
the low bass register most sparingly
throughout line.
This is partly explained by
the fact that Sibelius wanted
to create an impression
whereas Kreisler did not.
What is this impression?
This concerto is often
considered as--
or its orchestration is
considered dark, that's true,
ballads of fagatos, clarinets,
violoncelle, double basses,
timpani that Sibelius uses
and the violins, for example,
are playing quite low, not
very often high positions.
In the first-- no I think this
was the second critic in the U.S.,
the work was played first in
New York and the second one was
in Chicago in 1907, I think
in New York one year earlier.
The critic in "Chicago
Daily Tribune" wrote,
"this masterpiece is orchestrated
in strange and dark colors".
So this is something Sibelius wants
to emphasize and, on the other hand,
Kreisler does not want, perhaps.
Maybe in his mind, there
is a brighter sound
that he wants from the piano.
To some extent, Kreisler leaves
out this dark mainly
counteractive basses also contrary
to the orchestral score.
But these are just
rare, rare examples.
Here from the first movement,
it's very clear to be seen,
Sibelius version deep
basses, counteractive basses,
they don't actually exist.
Fagatos, double basses and
kettle drum play this one,
what we see in Kreisler's reduction.
Let's hear an example by, this is
Frank Patecioman [phonetic] right?
>> Yes, Helsinki [inaudible].
>> First example, just a moment.
[ Music ]
And then, from our CD.
So, what did you think?
What do you think?
How do you find it?
>> I pick yours.
>> At least we-- so in this
Kreisler version, it was,
there was same basses actually
like in the original version.
Some other examples from the third
movement, same thing, Sibelius,
deep basses, they do not
exist in the orchestral score.
And Kreisler uses the same basses
like in the orchestral score.
Another note, in his reduction,
Kreisler has a thinner texture
throughout the line which,
in some cases, demonstrates
a more pianistic approach.
Here maybe the best example of the
whole concerto also from the point
of the pianistic approach,
Kreisler uses--
here Kreisler uses tremolo instead
of chord triplets by Sibelius.
These kind of chords are not very
rewarding to play for a pianist.
And, I think, Kreisler found
here very elegant solution.
Let's hear how it sounds.
Think I have a technical problem.
Escape, yeah, yeah.
Sir?
>> Try moving up the [inaudible].
>> Okay. Oh.
[ Music ]
Another example from the
second movement, it's very easy
to see the very thick texture
in Sibelius's version,
Kreisler, light texture.
Or, from the third movement,
again, quite unpianistic writing
in Sibelius's version, Kreisler
makes it easier for a pianist and,
perhaps, this is also not
necessary for the sound image.
But we see, or hear,
in Sibelius's version.
There are also opposite examples
of thicker or thinner texture.
Kreisler, here, uses
chords, at the same time,
Sibelius just uses octaves
so a thicker texture in
Kreisler's reduction.
And also here, at the end of the
third movement, I think this gives--
this is the end of the whole
work, of course, this gives weight
for the last pass of the work to my
mind, maybe, gives more weight to--
it gives more, it emphasizes
the end better
than the octaves in
Sibelius's version.
Kreisler has some individual
simplifications compared
to the score in rhythms, harmonies,
or in leaving out the melodic line.
The first sample, for example,
from the first movement,
this is the original
one with the 16th note,
in Kreisler's version,
he leaves that away.
It sounds like this.
[ Music ]
So here we were already at the end.
Or in the first movement, there are
some simplified harmonies Kreisler
just leaves some harmonies away,
but these are very rare
examples in the whole work.
And the first movement, I don't
know if you can see something here,
it's very small, but there
are some slides on the paper.
I hope you get to this room.
Up here, there is a line, melodic
line played by oboes, clarinets,
fagatos, French horns, later
here by trombones and trumpets.
Kreisler just leaves it away.
Couple of these kind
of examples also
in this reduction by Fritz Kreisler.
And, again, on the other
hand, there are places
where Sibelius does not follow
the score and Kreisler follows.
In this example, the
melody should be on the beat
and it is the case in
Kreisler's reduction.
Sibelius, he, for some reason,
considered it otherwise.
In his reduction, Kreisler
has several appropriations
in the orchestra accompaniment
which actually are the
most significant changes
to Sibelius's chord.
Of course, if you leave
something away like in this,
maybe the most radical example,
it does perhaps some harm
for general form for the
architecture of the work.
But, on the other hand, and on the
whole, Kreisler's appropriations
to the orchestral score
seem very natural
and also are elegant solutions.
Here we wrote the bass Kreisler
leaves away, for example here,
10 bars, 2 bars here, this
part consists of 76 bars.
And here we just see 39 of them.
So, there are 9 places,
shortened by 37 bars all together.
Let's hear how it sounds.
[ Music ]
And so on.
Kreisler has some of his own
additions and simplifications
which support the sound image,
such as in the first movement,
he puts up, or moves up, the
melody played actually by fagatos
and violoncelle down here.
One octave higher like this.
This is perhaps one
indication more to the fact
that Kreisler had a brighter
sound in mind than Sibelius.
Or here, the rare example, Kreisler
just put some chords to the end
of the whole work, maybe to give
some [inaudible] for the end.
Or the third movement
beginning here,
the kettle drums are playing
this written [clapping].
And the strings are
playing [clapping].
And last one-- .
>> -- If we are doing it together,
it should sound like
this, I'm strings.
>> You're on strings,
okay [clapping].
And so on.
>> So it should sound all the
time [clapping] but it's not
when you are listening
to orchestral version,
the strings are more powerful so the
image you get from, at the audience,
it is bum ba ba, bum ba ba,
bum ba ba, rather than da, da,
da, da, da, da, da, da, da.
>> So, here, Kreisler
chooses the solution
that actually support
the sound image.
The example is now played by Jani.
This is?
>> This is [inaudible] symphony.
>> Yeah.
[ Music ]
As you can hear, even the timpani's
playing the rhythm, da, da, dun, da,
da, dun, da da dun, but what we hear
from the orchestra are
mostly the strings,
bum ba ba, bum ba ba, bum ba ba.
This is how it sounds
in Kreisler's reduction.
[ Music ]
So, come to the end.
Generally speaking, one can
emphasize the pragmatism
and pianistic approach
of Kreisler's reduction.
For example, Sibelius's reduction
has simply far more notes
in the chords, but that is
perhaps not always necessary
to create an impression.
Kreisler's appropriations
have been executed
with good taste and,
thus, sound natural.
And I would like to add to this
that leaving out the deep basses
or moving up the melodic line
here and there indicate that,
in his reduction, Kreisler
doesn't always want
to imitate the dark
sounds of the orchestra.
His intention seems to let the
piano sound a little bit brighter
than it does in Sibelius's
reduction.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Are there any questions
from the audience?
Questions?
Yeah, you have one?
>> So, one question that comes
up in my mind is the, in general,
it seems like a much more practical
solution that Kreisler is doing.
Do you know from, I know
that the date is not known
of this particular
transcription, but do you know
if it was his practice to perform a
concerto with a pianist in general,
in addition to his
orchestral performances?
So, is this something that he would
do and he just needed something
that was a more utilitarian
type of, for his personal use
of these types of reductions?
I don't know enough about
his performance habits
in the early days.
>> That's a good question.
As far as I know, Kreisler
played a lot
of concerts with different pianists.
And, for example, he recorded
all Beethoven's 1 sonatas
at least 3 times which
is quite a huge work.
So, recital concerts was
his main business actually.
And, but we don't know anything
about this work he made,
this reduction from
Sibelius's concerto.
We don't know did he play
it himself, but I guess,
I suppose that he was planning
to use this work in his recitals.
But, unfortunately, there's no
written documents about this.
>> But did he generally
have a pianist
when he was doing these recitals?
>> Yes, yes, of course.
>> But I meant more when he's doing
concerto reductions in performance,
was that part of his
staple repertory?
So not just the works that
are for violin and piano,
but also these types of reductions.
>> Well, I don't know, but during
his time, it was really common
to play every kind of music.
>> Everybody did this at the time.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> So I assume Kreisler did it too.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Still Jascha Heifetz
played lots of recitals
and playing concertos
as the first half.
For example, this Mendelssohn
Bartholdy E Minor Concerto was very
often played by him with piano.
And then, after intermission,
there was show pieces
and then some sonatas
and something like that.
>> Even if, yes, even if
he was already a superstar
who played with every orchestra.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> So, can I ask, what, you are
very, very interested in Kreisler.
What, in particular, got
you so fascinated by him?
>> Of course his works for
violin are very fascinating
for a violinist like me.
Or every other violinist should
be interested about his works.
Maybe that's the main
reason we became
so interested about his works.
And, of course, this recording
we have recorded some, was it 11
or 12 Kreislers showpieces
we played together?
>> Eleven.
>> Eleven, yeah.
And it was quite a big work to
produce these works as a CD and,
of course, we played those
works so much that we find
out all the time more
details from the score.
And so it was really
interesting job to do.
>> And from the pianist's
point of view, it's rewarding
to play Kreisler's score because
it's very pianistic always.
He was a good pianist too and you
can, you see it, you feel it always.
>> There's a question.
>> Are these 2 reductions played,
are they performed a lot today?
>> You mean?
>> Sibelius and Kreisler.
>> Kreisler not because
this is unpublished.
So we are using only copies
and it's not available
from music store or somewhere.
So, you have to come here to
U.S. Library to get copies so.
>> The Sibelius one?
>> Sibelius one, it's
available everywhere.
And also this Gretchaninoff
version of it-- .
>> -- Gretchaninoff too.
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> Mostly you play
the Sibelius version.
Of course, nowadays, reductions
are mostly played in concerts just
in choral works, from
the choral works.
Not so often anymore in this
kind of instrumental concertos.
>> Yeah, in fact, your
performance last night
at the Finnish Embassy
was probably the premiere
of this Kreisler reduction.
>> Yes, it could be true that it
might be the first time ever here
in the U.S. And, of course, we have
played these together somewhere
in Finland and, day
before yesterday,
we played it in Copenhagen when
it was Finnish National Day.
So that was actually the
first really public concert
of this version we gave.
>> Any other questions?
All right, well, we
have some music then
to round up this program, right?
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. So, Mike Turpin [phonetic]
back there has been handling
the technology.
>> So this is the third
movement of Sibelius's concerto
with Kreisler piano reduction
from the CD we made last year
and we are still looking
for a publisher for this CD.
So, if here is millionaires
[laughter].
[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you.
>> And if you're interested in
the manuscript, it's over there
and that's Fritz Kreisler's
[background music] childhood violin,
right?
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.